The ability to create custom
watch faces gives you direct
access to the most prominent UI element
on the user's most personal device.
And the API is simple enough to
build watch faces quickly and
flexible enough to
allow personalization.
Given the depth and flexibility of
the Android platform, you can create
something for the user that's both
beautiful and pact with unique features.
And here's a few design guidelines
that'll set the right context for
making these design decisions.
First, the Android wear comes
in multiple form factors.
So you want to make sure that your watch
faces work great on both round and
square watches.
Next, there are two primary states for
Android wear.
Interactive mode is in full color and
motion with fluid animation.
Now, this is typically when a user is
giving focused attention to their watch.
Ambient mode is a low power state and
it should use a limited color palette
that's only updated once a minute.
And finally, make sure to take
special screens into account.
On low bit screens,
pixels in ambient mode are either off or
on, which means you'll only want to use
black and white with no anti-aliasing.
You're also going to want to use burn-in
protection techniques with OLED screens,
like avoiding large
blocks of opaque pixels.
In fact, we recommend that around 95% of
the screen in ambient mode remain black.
Once you've finalized your design,
the best way to start developing is
either to start with a sample or
a template in Android Studio.
And there are three main methods which
you're going to want to know about.
First the onCreate method.
You'll take care of your initialization
tasks, such as loading resources or
initializing paint objects for
later use in this method.
You can scale these objects using
the onSurfaceChanged method.
And this method has the screen size
passed in as one of its parameters.
If you have a bitmap background,
or watch hands, this is a great place
to scale them to the right size.
At the core of the watchface
api is the onDraw method.
Now that allows you to draw whatever
design you can think of to the canvas at
a high enough frame rate
to deliver fluid animation.
Now, this is going to come through at
full fidelity while the watch is in
interactive mode.
And at other times when the watch
is in ambient mode, you're able to
draw a more discrete version of
the watch while also saving power.
Additional preferences can be set
to arrange the System UI elements
appropriately for your design.
Once those basics are covered,
the limits are your imagination.
You can go further with additions like,
I don't know a moon phase, the current
weather or even fitness stats.
Now watchmakers call these
items complications, but
with Android Wear they're
hardly complicated.
Once you have the data, just draw it
on the canvas as you did the time.